Shawn and it instantly lets you know the
answer fulfill appeal with investor well
are you looking to make a great return
on your money but you're worried about
an economic crash well yes I am
whatever I told you there's a secret
investment strategy of the rich and
famous a safe secure place to stash your
money while receiving dividends of four
five even six percent per year even when
the market dips sounds incredible but
that's not all
with investor well your money grows
tax-deferred from one year to the next
Uncle Sam you could use all the wealth
you build a plan for retirement awful
little Jimmy's a college tuition or a
new car in fact some people are so wild
about this investment they've used it as
a replacement for banks lending
institutions insurance and more why want
one what's it called whole life
insurance
[Music]
stop us if you've heard this one you've
been thinking about beginning your
investment journey so you sit down with
your local financial adviser and they
throw you a curveball whole life
insurance as an investment solution when
we asked 30% of you said you've had a
financial expert recommend it the rest
of you might be thinking life insurance
as an investment what are you talking
about
well as strange as that may appear on
its surface whole life insurance as an
investment has been around for
generations its life insurance that
never expires but that's just the
beginning
it has an investment component - that's
protected from the stock market and pays
attractive dividends pick the first book
on investing I ever read extolled the
amazing virtues of whole life insurance
let's start with life insurance 101 way
back in 1583 Richard Martin purchased
the first recorded life insurance policy
in England on his buddy William for 30
pounds one year later when will he died
Richard received a 400 pound payout nice
for him and not so nice for Willie
today the principle purpose of life
insurance is to protect those left
behind if a family member dies it's a
standard component of modern financial
planning with 59% of people in the u.s.
owning some kind of life insurance
here's how it works you pay a regular
premium to insure somebody's life if
that person dies while the policy is
still in force the insurance company
pays out a cash death benefit usually
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of dollars this money is meant to help
those they leave behind the most common
type is term life you have a flat
monthly premium for a set term usually
ten twenty or thirty years at the end of
the term if you're still breathing
premiums jump up dramatically and it's
not uncommon to cancel your policy at
that point but whole life insurance is
different it has consistent
lack premiums for your whole life how
can they afford to do that by charging a
much higher premium part of that goes
towards the cost of insurance and part
of it into an investment account called
the cash value which pays a dividend of
four to six percent per year the purpose
of this account is to offset the
increasing cost of insurance as you get
older so your premiums stay flat unlike
term life if you cancel a whole life
policy you might get some money back
depending on how long you've had it you
could even get more than you paid into
it some advisors recommend that instead
of borrowing from a bank and you could
take out loans against your cash value
while keeping the insurance in place a
practice dubbed infinite banking
advocates of whole life treated as a
financial silver bullet for your needs
life insurance without an expiration
date a tax deferred investment for your
future by your banker and alone money to
yourself how can term life possibly hold
a candle to this I think it's time to
run the numbers
tia and tamera are twins both age 40 and
are shopping for life insurance tea
epochs whole life while Tamera picks a
30-year term life the death benefit for
each is $500,000 Tia will be paying 563
per month for a whole life policy
according to u.s. averages that's pretty
steep
but Tia was attracted to the cash value
growth she's thinking this will count as
some of her investing each year and that
five point five percent is a pretty good
return hold on to you the five point
five percent dividend only applies to
your cash value portion not the full
five sixty three payment according to a
2015 Consumer Reports study after costs
like commissions and fees the average
whole life investment return was closer
to 2% if Tia lives to age 70 she'll have
paid two hundred and two thousand six
hundred eighty dollars in premiums but
her policy will have a cash value worth
almost 280 grand
she's been insured her whole life and
made money sounds like a win to me now
Tamera's thirty year term life is
costing her fifty two dollars each month
if she also lives 270 she gets nothing
back so Tamera decides to invest the
difference between her premium and what
she might have paid for a whole life
policy and if she invests in a basic
stock index fund shall probably average
over seven percent for the next thirty
years at seventy her life insurance will
be worthless but her investment will be
worth over $600,000 that's twice as much
as Tia got with her whole life policy so
with high premiums and underwhelming
returns why is whole life recommended by
brokers and advisors across the country
one word commissions see agents and
advisors typically receive a commission
of eighty to a hundred percent of the
annual premium so Tamera's agent made
only six hundred bucks
but Tia's made around six grand when I
first started my financial career I too
drank the kool-aid it was clear that our
Commission's would be much higher for
recommending any insurance product with
an investment component our clients were
often unaware of this conflict of
interest to be fair there are some
situations that might
whole life insurance a good fit like a
family with a special-needs child who
needs a lifetime of support or owning a
complicated family business or a sizable
estate with substantial taxes but these
are special cases it's not the
one-size-fits-all remedy it's made out
to be it's best to do your own research
read the fine print and make sure you're
seeking objective advice from somebody
that doesn't have financial skin in the
game but white bears and that's our two
cents if you have any experience with
term or whole life insurance share with
us in the comment section